طيب يعني ركزلي مره اخرى واكد لي على
نوعيه هذه المصادر المفتوحه حسب تجربتك
واي هذه المصادر يمكن ان نقول بانه اكثر
اهميه من حيث توفير كميه المعلومات ومن
حيث دقتها
المصادر المفتوحه
والمصطلح الدرجه الان هو المعلومات
المتاحه للعامه ولكن هذا المصطلح يعطينا
مفهوما عن طبيعتها استطيع ان اذكر في
قائمه طويله من المصادر او لكن الابسط ان
نفكر في الامر على اهم المسار المفتوحه
المعلومات العامه المتاحه
قانونيا ومجانا او فقط مجانا وحسب مجالي
والذي
هو من اختصاصي وهو
التكنولوجيا نسبه 85% قد تصل الى مئه
بالمئه اي العملات استخبارتيه جمع
المعلومات العلميه والتكنولوجيه والعلماء
حول العالم يسرهم التحدث عن اعمالي مو
انجازاتهم ومن هنا نجمع هذه المعلومات
وحتى الوكالات المموله ايضا
تعلن المنح ولمن تمنحها وهذه ايضا مصدرا
جيد للمعلومات استخباراتيه لجمع المعلومات
العلميه والتكنولوجيا لا اريد ان اعطني
طباعه المفتوح السهله كيف الحقيقه صعبه
لان المصادر تجف اذا لم تستخدم بحذر كما
ان الكميه في حد ذاتها تجعلها مخيفه
وعاده المصادر تكون بلغات اجنبيه
وعلى نتعامل مع صادر المفتوحه بنفس
المهارات والسلوكيات التي يستخدمها
الجامعون والمحللون للمعلومات السريه وفي
الختام هيا نفس المهنه ونفس المنهجيات